vous souvenez certainement de ces
événements ces graffitis de croix gammée
qui avait soulevé l'indignation dans le
quartier notre-dame-de-grâce cet hiver
bien le maire de montréal a pris cet
exemple là aujourd'hui a décidé à nom
aussi qu'il y avait calé qu'il y allait
avoir une escouade françois de la police
de montréal contre les crimes haineux
effectivement patrice on nous promet que
ce sera une structure unique au québec
voire même en amérique du nord denis
coderre en a fait l'annoncé alors qu'il
était allé témoigner en commission
parlementaire aujourd'hui sur le projet
de loi concernant les discours haineux
on nous parle donc d'une unité spéciale
de prévention en matière d'incidents et
de créer mais ne vous avez donc entendu
le mot prévention pensons par exemple à
cette policière qui avait été posté
trois jours semaine dans le collège de
maisonneuve lorsqu'il y avait eu
plusieurs incidents par rapport à la
radicalisation
on nous dit que ce serait également une
unité qui sera responsable de trouver
les meilleures pratiques pour à travers
le monde pour agir lorsqu'il y à des
crimes haineux on écoute là dessus le
maire denis coderre à vinça faisait
partie de la requête et tout ça mais là
quelque chose vraiment de spécifiques en
termes de prévention
on a déjà l'expertisé de cette une
réorganisation qui va permettre
justement de pouvoir
se pencher davantage la toussaint poser
quand nos plus se le dit que dans termes
de réorganisation en termes de
gouvernance on pensait que c'était la
chose à faire
patrice ne me demandez pas combien il y
aura de policiers sur cette unité
spéciale
le maire coderre nous a dit on vous fera
suivant deuxième mes mots lorsque
viendra le temps de l'annoncé et on n'a
pas non plus les budgets louis en fait
vous l'avez entendu le maire parlait
plutôt d'une réorganisation des
ressources
ce ne sera pas ce ne seront pas de
nouvelles ressources qui seront ajoutés
au service de police de la ville de
montréal c'est noté merci françois au
revoir